[Музика]
Привіт всім, мене звати Наталія Алеско
, пора уроку англійської мови, давайте
почнемо,
тому сьогодні ми продовжуємо говорити про
спорт,
тому пам'ятайте, що на попередньому уроці ми
написали електронного листа,
тож давайте обговоримо це та виправимо
помилки
тому що, якщо ви пам’ятаєте, я сказав вам, що
навмисне зробив деякі помилки,
тож давайте подивимося на текст,
прочитайте його,
тож давайте разом перевіримо привіт Ліна,
дякую за вашу електронну пошту, було приємно
почути від вас
про вашу подію, щоб ви
бачили  Перша помилка тут від вас про
вашу подію або вашу
подію так, це має бути ваша подія,
тому давайте розглянемо всі помилки,
давайте йти далі в моїй школі ми проводимо
спортивний захід, який
називається Маленька олімпіада, це відбувається,
тому
пройдіть тут, це  помилка,
тому що це третя особа
однини,
і це має бути правильно,
давайте йти далі, у нас на стадіоні
це неправильно  d про
гру у
волейбол граматично речення
правильне
я був і ви дайте прикметник я був
сумний я був красивий я був розумний
я був щасливий, але давайте подивимося на саме
речення
я був дуже сумний про гру у волейбол
і команда виграла  срібна медаль, де
ви сиділи
і курили, не має сенсу,
тому я, ймовірно, був схвильований
або щасливий, це більше підходить для цього
речення,
давайте перейдемо до наступної помилки
після їжі та напоїв, якщо ви подивитеся
на речення
їжа та напої, це  два слова
правильні,
і багато людей кажуть, що нам потрібно
використовувати множину,
як там, але це неправильно,
тому що їжа - це перше слово, і воно є
одниною
, тому ми повинні сказати, що була їжа
та напої,
давайте перейдемо до останнього, що я відчув
схвильований,
що все закінчилося збуджений означає
враджані, тому yabo vrajani показувати події,
це знову не має сенсу, тому, ймовірно,
тут нам потрібно використати слово
set, мені було сумно, що все закінчилося,
тепер давайте подивимося на правильний
текст і
давайте прочитаємо його разом слідкуйте за мною привіт Ліна,
дякую за вашу електронну пошту, було приємно
почути від вас
про вашу подію в моїй школі ми проводимо
спортивний захід під назвою Маленька олімпіада,
який проходить щороку 1 червня на
стадіоні біля
нашої школи  подія наповнена
різними видами діяльності
діти можуть грати у футбол та
волейбол, вони також можуть брати участь у спринтерських заходах
цього року подія була чудовою,
я був дуже схвильований тим, що граю у
волейбол,
також моя команда виграла срібну медаль, тому я
відчував, що я
дуже пишався після їжі та
напоїв  був чудовий день, і мені було сумно, що
все закінчилося,
Наталія, тепер це правильно,
і сьогодні ми можемо рухатися далі, у нас буде
урок граматики,
тож давайте почнемо, давайте подивимося на
приклад, у
нас двоє хлопців розмовляють, так що Джону було
боляче  сам, тому він не може бігати
сьогодні,
що означає біг підтюпцем, ти пам'ятаєш,
так, це як біг,
так що Джон поранився собі,
Джон поранив себе, давайте подивимося на
наступну фразу t  Шкода, я думаю, що тоді я буду
бігати сам,
так що шкода мені дуже шкода чути
про Джона
де Хеа, тому
я думаю, що я буду бігати
сам,
так, якийсь педофіл і остання фраза
не  хвилюйтеся, я приєднаюся до вас, якщо вам подобаються
кусачки,
тож якщо ви подивитеся на ці два приклади,
Джон поранився,
і я думаю, що я піду бігом сам, щоб
ви вже зрозуміли, що ми
будемо говорити про
зворотні займенники,
тож давайте почнемо  мати форми однини
та форми множини
однини - це я сам,
сам і сам і множина - це
ми самі і самі,
як приклад, подивіться тут, тому якщо у
вас є займенник, який
вона каже, якщо ви хочете зробити зворотний
займенник,
щоб вона почула себе
правильно, ми  не можу сказати, що вона чула,
вона поранилася, тому давайте ще раз
повторимо,
вона сама молодець
, ходімо далі, він допоможи мені
сам, браво, він сам
виправив, у нас є.
знову йти бігати
сам
i  я молодець
давайте йти далі вони
самі будьте обережні з цим закінченням
самі молодці вони самі
наступний ми самі
давайте подивимося на цю частину ах ми вимовляємо
це не
ми самі, але ми самі робимо це
швидше
давайте спробуємо ще раз,
щоб ми самі були
досконалими  і давайте подивимося на це
ви ви
самі, так що ви вивчаєте англійську мову самі
добре, або ви перевіряєте себе,
ви перевіряєте себе, і це в однині
я говорю про вас як про одну людину, але
якщо я буду говорити про вас стільки людей,
я б сказав собі це  по-
іншому подивіться тут у таблиці однини
ми маємо
себе одну людину самі
багато учнів,
тому ще раз як одна людина ви
самі і ви, як мої учні,
самі дякуємо, тож давайте перейдемо далі,
коли ми використовуємо зворотні займенники,
давайте спочатку подивимося  з усіх, що ми використовуємо
їх з дієсловами, як
burn cut hurt
look at teach та інші,
коли підмет і об’єкт
дієслів однакові,
що це означає su  об'єкт і
об'єкт подивіться я себе пошкодив,
отже я суб'єкт, а я є
об'єктом,
і це одна людина це я
або я навчаюся сам
я, як учитель навчаю себе
я суб'єкт, і я є об'єктом
тут,
так що це  чому я використовую тут зворотний займенник,
давайте подивимося на приклад,
який сама Саллі мала, граючи в хокей,
Саллі порано,
давайте подивимося на пояснення, Саллі
почула, Саллі, так що
Саллі є суб'єктом, а Саллі є
об'єктом, тому ми використовуємо
тут зворотний займенник,
давайте перейдемо далі  Наприклад, ми використовуємо
зворотні займенники
з або без by, щоб показати, що хтось
зробив щось самостійно або без
будь-якої допомоги,
тому я навчаюся сам, мені не потрібна допомога,
або давайте подивимося на цей приклад Кріс
встановив
тренажер сам, він зробив  t використовує будь-яку допомогу він
не просив допомоги
він зробив це сам вінс роберт каже
samostino
sam bestopo давайте перейдемо до ще
одного прикладу, ми використовуємо зворотні
займенники
у фразах, як-от насолоджуйся
або поводися чи допомагай собі  f
будь собою або зроби це сам,
наприклад, давайте подивимося на приклад,
допоможи собі фрукти,
це повинно бути так,
допоможи собі, значить, зробіть це без будь-якої
допомоги, поведи себе, доведіть, що сказав
підборіддя,
поводься так
добре, і будь собою, це все одно, що
знову розслабитися  і не грайте жодних ролей, будьте
собою,
давайте подивимося на дуже важливі речі,
тому зверніть увагу, що
ми не використовуємо зворотні займенники з
дієсловом, наприклад
зустрітися, розслабитися зосередитися
і я не можу сказати, що ви повинні
спробувати розслабитися
roslabs we don't  t скажи так,
ми говоримо, що просто розслабся, ти повинен спробувати
розслабитися
або я зустрічаюся з собою, або я зустрічаюся з собою
знову, це не має сенсу, тому
з дієсловами, як
зустрітися, розслабитися, зосередитися і
не відчувати зворотних займенників добре,
гм, давайте трохи потренуємося, тому завдання
бо
ви подивіться, у нас є вісім речень, а у
нас є займенники, у якийсь момент
нам не потрібно додавати зворотний займенник, який
ви пам’ятаєте,
розслабтеся, зосередьтеся, почувайтеся та не зустрічаєте
займенник
добре, тому подивіться на речення, які я даю вам
одну милю
Ну подумай над реченнями, а потім ми
разом перевіримо
[Музика]
Зробимо
тож давайте разом перевіримо Гаррі
вчить
грати на гітарі Гаррі він
Гаррі вчить себе молодець
кейт грав у гольф вчора до побачення,
Кейт  дівчина Кейт сама грала в гольф
вчора сама ідеальна номер три
Джейк любить розслаблятися
після важкого тренування в тренажерному залі, тому
я знаю, що ви хочете сказати, що Джейк
любить розслаблятися сам,
але чи можливо ні, ви
пам'ятаєте слово
relax we don't  t використовуйте зворотні займенники, так що
Джейк любить розслаблятися після важкого тренування
в тренажерному залі № 4, Саллі
та Марк приготував салат, Саллі та
Марк
двох людей, так що самі молодці
Саллі та Марк приготували салат
самі
ідеальний номер п'ять, насолоджуйтесь
на футбольному матчі Алан Со  ви
розмовляєте з Аланом
Алленом, це схоже на вас, тому ми говоримо, що
насолоджуйтесь ідеально, насолоджуйтеся на
футбольному матчі Хелен
номер шість гуртів у лікарні
Бен перебуває в лікарні, він почув, коли
грав у регбі,
тому  тут у нас є натяк, що він нашкодив
собі, браво номер сім
я не допоміг Бет з її домашнім завданням,
вона зробила це сама, тому вона все
зробила сама, без допомоги,
і останній, чи можете ви мені допомогти,
я не можу все винести
я молодець, тож давайте прочитаємо ще раз,
я не можу винести
все сам досконало, тому
ще раз номер один сам
номер два це ти
сам номер три ніщо
номер чотири самі номер п'ять
сам
номер шість сам номер сім
сам і останній сам
зараз давайте  швидко перевірте ще раз із
займенником, тому я даю вам особистий профі
зараз, а ви дайте мені зворотний, так що
ви
самі ідеально молодці,
вона сама,
він сам, і знову
він сам,
давай навпаки сам, що для нього є
особистим займенником
я молодець
я вдосконалююсь
вони молодці і останній
ми самі і знову
ми самі
дякую, давайте рухаємося далі,
тому настав час для вас, давайте
з невеликим
тестом подивіться у мене є fo  Ваші пропозиції для
вас
представили решті класу,
і ми маємо три відповіді ab
або c, вам потрібно вибрати найбільш
відповідну відповідь, скажімо, я даю вам 40
секунд,
а потім ми разом перевіримо
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож давайте  перевірте разом перше
речення
Анна представила правильну
відповідь
ab або cb правильна
Анна представилася
решті класу
anna presta клас
номер два будь ласка, будь ласка, вдома Tom
a будь собою
або побачимося, яка правильна відповідь
тут
так, ми  у Тома, це одна людина,
тож правильна відповідь:
будь ласка, почувайся як вдома, Томе, але ти
перейдемо до номеру три. Я почав
вчитися грати на
гітарі три роки тому, яка правильна
відповідь.
я почав
вчитися грати на гітарі сам,
а останнє ми пригощаємо
відпустку в Іспанії,
тому ми пригощаємо себе,
будьте самі, побачите самі,
яка правильна відповідь, а
ми самі  нагадуємо себе про відпустку
в Іспанії,
тому ми
самі молодці, а тепер давайте
подивимося, у нас є п’ять речень,
і це буде схоже на діалект, у
нас є запитання,
і у нас є відповідь на нього, тому
давайте вивчимо на прикладі людину
a запитує, чи купив він цей шоколад для
нас,
і відповідає ні, він купив його
собі,
ви бачите слово в дужках так і ні,
і,
як ви бачите, усі відповіді ні, тому нам
потрібно виправити інформацію,
тому чи він купив свій шоколад  для нас
ні, він купив це для себе,
давайте вивчимо приклад номер два ти
готуєш сніданок для Джеймса,
це питання, як ви бачите з
прикладу, який ми використовуємо,
так що це дуже просто. Давайте складемо
речення ти приготував сніданок для
Джеймса, і відповідь має бути  будь ні
, ти приготував сніданок для Джеймса
ні я приготував сніданок для себе,
тому ти виправив інформацію, зараз я
даю тобі
дві хвилини, щоб записати речення,
а потім ми разом перевіримо
іноземні
[Музика]
[Музика  c]
тож давайте разом перевіримо, подивіться на
номер
два, ви приготували сніданок для Джеймса ні, я
приготував його для себе, чи не могли б ви повторити,
будь ласка,
ні, я приготував це для себе, молодці,
давайте підемо з номером три, вони
планують вечірку, Деббі,
яке має бути питання
вони планували вечірку для Деббі
ні, вони планували це для себе,
тож скажімо ще раз, чи вони планували
вечірку для Деббі,
ні, вони планували це для себе,
давайте з номером чотири crease by
CDs і ми,
то що має бути питання,
чи Кріс купив
компакт-диски  для нас
ні, він купив їх собі,
тож скажімо знову, чи Кріс купив
міста для нас,
ні, він купив їх собі,
давайте подивимося на останній, Моллі принесла
квіти
для вас, тож давайте складемо речення,
чи Молі принесла квіти
для вас і  відповідь має бути ні,
ні, вона принесла їх собі
, скажімо знову, чи Моллі принесла
вам квіти;
ні, вона принесла їх собі,
тепер у вас є свої нотатки перед собою
або ви можете подивитися на екран, який
я даю вам  Питання, а ти дай
мені відповідь добре,
так що
готово, ходімо, ти приготував сніданок
для Джеймса
ні, я приготував його для себе, добре,
давайте спробуємо ще раз, чи Моллі принесла
вам квіти
ні, вона принесла їх собі, добре
, він купив це  шоколад для нас
ні, він купив його собі
, подивіться на слово шоколад тут
ми називаємо його як їж шоколад плитка
шоколаду
давайте продовжимо зменшуватися містами
для нас
ні він купив їх собі
і чи планували вони вечірку для Деббі
ні  вони запланували це для себе,
тож якщо я дам вам слова, як-от Моллі,
це речення номер п'ять, то чи можете ви
дати мені відповідь,
Молі ні, вона принесла їх собі,
якщо я скажу, Кріс,
ні, він купив їх собі,
якщо я сказав, Деббі, це номер  три
ні, вони запланували це для себе,
якщо я сказав Джеймсу,
ні, я приготував це для себе ідеально,
тому ваше домашнє завдання для наступного уроку
складіть власні речення зі
зворотними займенниками,
а дієслова cut teach насолоджуйтеся
допомогою та поводьтеся так cut is
що це таке вчити нафкатіс
насолоджуватися
та пам'ятати, що у нас є чотири дієслова, які ми
не використовуємо
зворотні займенники з чим вони
зустрічаються розслаблятися, сконцентруватися
та відчувати, і я чую, як дзвенить м'яч, це
означає, що нам потрібно припинити урок,
дуже дякую за  приєднуйся до мене,
побачимося наступного разу,
до побачення
[Музика].